everybody excited to be here my name is
Franklin socket and today I'll be
talking about building a data-driven
organization this is about scaling my
business 150 fold with people processes
and tools so currently I'm the
co-founder and CTO of authentic real
estate analytics before that I was a
facebook data scientist and before that
I was a high frequency trading quant
so at authentic what we do is we predict
if homeowners are going to sell their
house within the next six months to an
investor and then we so our clients are
highly competitive residential investors
who are looking for an edge in doing
their marketing so they're looking for
off-market deals stuff that other people
are not necessarily looking at and then
they do direct marketing to contact the
owners themselves so our product is used
in over 250 markets across the country
and we're growing every day so scaling
150 fold so basically what that means is
we started the business with one client
a Macbook and a CSV file
everything was ad-hoc so started with
you know after a few months you know we
we were able to deliver a data set to
our first client of the twenty thousand
people that were most likely to sell to
an investor so that client went out they
did some direct marketing they got some
leads they close some deals and we were
able to basically get some word-of-mouth
from there and grow our clients over the
last four years we've grown the business
through people processes and tools but
not in that order tools are the
foundation of data science and the
processes are what helped us become more
automated but we all know that data
science isn't repeatable isn't really
data science so hence the focus on the
tools and the processes so the way that
I approached it was starting first with
the tools picking the right things to be
using Python being the the main tool
from there
we added in processes so that we were
from ad-hoc one-off work to consistency
and then once we outgrew that we started
adding more people to the team and
growing and innovating on the tools and
the processes and the people and it
became a nice feedback loop so starting
with the tools
Buckminster Fuller said if you want to
teach people a new way of thinking don't
bother trying to teach them instead give
them a tool the use of which will lead
to new ways of thinking so the concept
here is that we're by choosing a tool by
using a specific tool we're actually
giving up control for speed and so
that's really the essence of using the
right tools you basically basically can
free up the cognitive load of making
continuous decisions and gives you way
more space to be creative the tools
actually enforce a certain way of
thinking that when you're using the
right tool that the thinking follows
with that so as an example we in the
team started using black which is a a
code formatter and it sounds like a kind
of a trivial example but basically what
we were able to do is have a uniform
code style so I'm sure a lot of people
have read Google has their own coding
style and they have a document and you
read it and you learn how they like to
format their code well this basically
removes all that and it says this
there's only one way to format your code
you run it through black it's always
outputted the exact same way the name
was actually from Henry Ford where he
said people could have any car any color
of car that they wanted as long as it
was black so basically what black says
on their website is by using it you
agree to cede control over the minutia
of hand formatting in return black gives
you speed determinism and freedom from
PI code style nagging about formatting
you will save time and mental energy for
more important matters so the biggest
benefit for us was actually when we were
starting to do pull requests and
everybody was formatting their code with
black instead of there being different
lines of code were changed but it was
really just a formatting the disks
became way smaller
way faster and much easier to understand
so as we were building out the the tools
stack for our product
each tool that we chose really kind of
enforced a certain way of thinking and
taught us something that we didn't
necessarily know beforehand so these are
some of the tools that we use on a daily
basis and sort of like the category what
the tool is and what we learned from it
so just digging in I would say that
probably the one of the more powerful
tools that we also use is air flow and
so we've gone through a few different
tools and iterations using Luigi using
Jenkins for some automation and kind of
cobbling together system but air flow
really enforces a way of thinking and
approaching data engineering with a with
a highly opinionated framework right
you have to use air flow the way that
they created it I would say an
anti-pattern for for tools is bike
shedding it's also known as Parkinson's
law of triviality so the example that's
given is that if you're designing a
atomic nuclear reactor people will wind
up arguing more over the color of the
bike shed where they're going to park
their bikes as they're going there
rather than the actual heavy waiting
that the more interesting and harder
issues because it's easier to grasp what
color you should choose so you don't
want to spend too much time on the tools
the tool is sort of like are important
but it's very easy to have a ton of
arguments over which framework to use
and and all this stuff and it's not
always that important so there's the
hence why it's an anti-pattern okay so
next we move from tools to processes W
Edwards Deming so he was a statistician
and and consultant who was actually
credited with a lot of the Japanese
economic miracle of the 1950s and so
basically one of the quotes that he has
is
85% of the reasons for failure are
deficiencies in the systems and
processes rather than the employee the
role of management is to change the
processes rather than badgering
individuals to do better so he has
another quote that I really like a bad
system will beat a good person every
time so the more ad hoc your process is
the easier it is for it to break the
easier it is to forget steps the easier
is for to not be repeatable and we all
know repeatability and data science is
essential if you can't get the same
result twice it's it's not clear you
know which one was right what changed
what are you doing differently so the
focusing on the processes isn't is the
next step so on day one of the business
I was basically a mechanical turk so
there's this story of a chess-playing
machine that toured around Europe in the
18th century and they they used the
machine to play against Napoleon and
Benjamin Franklin and the Machine kept
winning later it was revealed and
discovered that there was actually a
tiny person inside the machine playing
so what looked like this incredibly
complex machine that could think and do
all these things it was really just a
person and so that was in a lot of ways
what this business was it was me
cobbling together a lots of different
processes and tools and outputs and
things like that making it look like it
was a software a product but every day I
came back to work thinking about how do
we automate this how do we turn this
into a process how do we write code to
connect the dots things like that so
these were three things that I focused
on for our processes first was a tool
called process Street and this is a
great tool it's a place where you can
actually write down your processes and
create checklists that are dynamic and
then you can for example for onboarding
a new client every time you on board a
new client you run a new checklist it
has inputs outputs and it steps you
through like what you need to be doing
second is ok ours
so Google is very famous for using a
okay ours it was popularized by venture
capitalist John Doerr and it stands for
objectives and key results so it's
beyond goal setting which a lot of
people have goals goals can only kind of
get you so far
you actually have to break down how
you're gonna do it and and that's what
the framework of okay ours really
provides you with and then finally is
the concept of minimum viable product
versus minimum viable feature versus
minimum viable change so you know
everybody starts with the idea we're
going to create this Minimum Viable
Product it's actually not granular
enough so I'll go through each one of
these so basically on the verge of
burnout I decided to write down what I
was doing and just documented right
especially if we're gonna add anybody
for me to train them it was gonna be so
much easier if I wrote down all the
stuffs that I did but this was before we
even had any more data scientists so I
personally just documented my own
process turned it into a checklist and
started onboarding clients by using
process Street and it really reduced the
brain damage I wasn't forgetting steps I
didn't have to go back and repeat and
fix mistakes and stuff like that and so
the other huge benefit was that my
co-founder stopped asking me like where
are we like is it done
how much longer like he could log in to
process tree and see we were on step 7
out of 12 so it added communication it
added repeatability all sorts of things
I highly recommend process Street
so moving on to ok ours so this is
objectives and key results and this is a
quote from John Doerr the objective is
what I want to have accomplished the key
results are how I'm going to get it done
the objectives are typically
longer-lived they're bold and
aspirational the key results are
aggressive but always measurable time
bound and limited a number and so when
we were starting you know we have this
idea of what we wanted to do what we
wanted to accomplish but
making it actually measurable was was
challenging and we didn't really have a
framework for it so we kind of kept
having the same conversation over and
over again like what are we going to do
today and basically you can break down
the okay hours into five benefits so the
benefit is it's this acronym facts so
the first one is focus you kind of
decide beforehand like what are we going
to focus on you know the the the last
speaker said one of the things that
kills a start-up is not knowing what
you're focusing on right like there's
too many things to do and so you just
start chasing your own tail and you get
all distracted next is alignment
everybody is kind of on the same page
you don't have to have the same
conversation of prioritization every day
we have prioritization in in the form of
alignment commitment you know people can
just say like I'm not gonna work on that
or I'm gonna work on that but either way
you get buy-in and then you have
tracking so the metrics aspect is huge
because you can actually say how close
you are to your goal and finally
stretching you know you can make your
goal more aggressive and you can track
and see like if you're making it too
aggressive or or not so another concept
is that every model should have a single
target metric so we all know that
there's there's all sorts of different
ways to measure a model you can do a you
see you can do f1 you can do precision
or recall and so when you start looking
at too many metrics it's really hard to
compare your model even against itself
with different data sets with different
periods of time so having something that
gives you a uniformity in how your model
is performing is it's pretty essential
so for for actually using the okrs how
we did it was we said we want to create
a model to predict who is most likely to
sell their house so that's the objective
and that's what the client wants we
that's you know it's something that's a
little bit more qualitative the key
result
and our single metric is the percentage
of houses that sold that we captured in
a portion of the list so we said we
wanted to capture 80% of the sales
within the highest twenty percent
probability of the data set and so the
reason we use that metric instead of
something like a UC is that a UC
optimizes generally over the whole data
set so if you're getting better you know
predictions at the back end of the of
the probabilities that doesn't really
help you when you're cutting it off at
the beginning you know our clients don't
want to talk to everybody they can't
afford to and if they could they
wouldn't need us anyway so we're trying
to give them the smallest sliver of the
data set you know the 50 people that are
the most likely to sell their house and
so that's why we chose this metric and
the metric really has to be custom to
like what you're trying to accomplish in
a business sense so using a UC would
have been you know it would've been okay
but it wouldn't have really helped us
know how on target we are another okay
are that we had was that we wanted to
automate the labeling of the data for
building a model so all sales were not
equal to us there are certain people
that were selling retail with a a
realtor stuff like that so we were
trying to remove those from the data set
but they're kind of harder to identify
we were looking for a certain type of
transaction that an investor would be
able to buy the house actually add value
to it so a lot of our clients are
flippers or they're you know landlords
they want to take a house that's being
underutilized really invest some capital
into the house make it a better product
and then either sell it or rent it to
people so so that required actually a
lot of labeling and the more clients
that we added the bigger our data set
that we were trying to train over
because we were trying to train over
Florida and California and Illinois and
Texas and so you get very different data
across these markets so we needed to
label data from each one of these local
markets so you just started getting into
real scale problems so the objective was
automate the labeling it's much harder
than it sounds and so basically the key
result was that we wanted to be able to
real able by hand a hundred rows in ten
minutes so I think that's like mmm one
every eight seconds or something like
that but to do that and to know like how
we were doing in terms of the automation
and the scalability of this we just
timed ourself like how long was it
actually taking us how do we bring this
thing down and then we figured out you
know the github issues and tasks of you
know platform tools and all that stuff
but this was what we needed to do this
is what we figured out our capacity
needed to be and then we could back out
the actual tasks that we needed to do
because we were measuring it against
this metric so we actually built a
little bit of active learning platform
with a human in the loop so we built a
model to predict the label and then we
took the labels and we built the
predictive model without knowing the
answer right so in the act of learning
you can cheat you can say this was a
good deal or this one was not now you
have your label data and then you can
put it into the the model afterwards so
does that make sense to everybody the
active learning part okay okay and then
the third process that we really tried
to harness was the the MVP versus
Minimum Viable feature versus Minimum
Viable change and so the reason for for
this process and and how we approached
our workflow was that speed really
matters
size matters and what I mean by speed
matters is Marc Andreessen said cycle
time compression may be the most
underestimated force in determining
winners and losers in tech and so the
cycle time is is how fast you can go
from you know idea to delivering value
to the client and so if it takes you a
super long time to develop to deliver a
ton of value you know that's okay but if
you can deliver less value quicker and
iterate this
chart which I stole from gitlab shows
that where you think so the the the one
the straight line is to where you think
the solution is and the in the bottom
right it's where the solution actually
was and so you start tracking that way
and as you make smaller and smaller
changes you realize you know you're not
really on the right track and so the way
that you can accomplish that is through
the idea that size matters which is like
the ostrich versus the hummingbird
hummingbirds are really fast and larger
changes are fraught with a lot of risk
so if you're only releasing your product
once a year you know you're not going to
get a lot of feedback if it breaks got a
big problem and it's really hard to wind
stuff back but if you're releasing daily
or weekly you know you're gonna get a
lot more feedback and you're gonna be
able to learn a lot more from how the
clients are using the product etcetera
so so that's processes finally we come
up to people so a certain point one
person can only do so much you need more
people five people can only do so much
and so Steve Jobs said great things in
business are never done by one person
they're done by a team of people we all
know that you know we all we all work on
teams and companies and but on the other
hand he said I noticed that the dynamic
range between what an average person
could accomplish and what the best
person could accomplish was 50 or 100 to
1 so given that you're well advised to
go after the cream of the cream a small
team of A+ players can run circles
around a giant team of B and C players
so when I was trying to build out the
team and you know we kind of had a blank
slate we I struggled you know we
struggled we had a few bad hires at the
beginning people that were great people
but they just didn't have the right
skill set for where we were how small we
were and how well-rounded they really
needed to be so they were so somebody
that can be great in a in a big company
because they can be very specialized
it's not always the best pick for
you know a two-person startup where they
need to wear a lot of different hats
so I listed a few of my anti-patterns
like some of the mistakes that I made
when trying to hire so first thing was
asking candidates different questions
making it difficult to compare them I
mean we'd get into the middle of a phone
screen and I'd start coming up with new
questions to ask people and I had no
idea basically what I was doing and I
found it very difficult to even ask
questions that really could like reveal
the type of skills that I was looking
for spending too long on the phone
screen when it was a bad fit so
sometimes you can realize real quickly
like this isn't going to work out and I
just finished out the half hour trying
to automate the technical screening with
hacker rank so I think this is a great
solution for software developers but
it's not a great solution yet for data
scientists so I would have them do you
know coding challenges and it was like
solver so when we used was like solve a
game where you had to have like forget
in the name of the game doesn't really
matter but the point is it was like
solve this game and it was just like for
loops and stuff like that and so even if
somebody could solve it it just didn't
mean that they're gonna be a great data
scientist but they might have good
Python skills so and then some people
would want to do it in JavaScript and so
I was like oh that sounds fine you know
language agnostic and all that stuff but
like we don't use JavaScript so you know
now they're gonna have to learn a whole
new language basically stuff like that
so you need people that can like kind of
already have been they're going too slow
and losing candidates competitors you
know when you're when you're trying to
do all the work yourself and then make
time for hiring you you know a day or
two slips and then somebody else is
moving faster and they pick them up
going too fast and hiring because we
needed someone now do that a couple
times you know so you can't just hire
because you need help you can't go slow
and only choose the perfect person
because they'll find something else to
do so there's a lot of balance here and
there's a lot of ways to make mistakes
there's a thousand ways to make mistakes
it's very difficult to to do it the
right way but you know eventually we got
some
big wins and we got a really great team
and so so here were some of the themes
of the people that we did hire and stuck
with us for a while no background in
real estate nobody had ever done
anything in real estate worked on coding
projects or cattle competitions in their
spare time so they just liked doing this
for fun you know you can do anything in
your spare time and if you're doing
Kaggle that's a good sign
degrees in economics computer science
physics engineering you know they're all
slightly technical if economics was
probably the least technical but none of
these are really data science and you
can't really get an undergrad degree in
data science so you know that wasn't
very predictive like what their degree
was in wide age range like you know
sometimes young people were better
sometimes older people were better wide
working experience we had people that
had PhDs and physics and we had people
that had been data scientists insurance
companies so like you know lots of
different experiences couldn't predict
who would complete the take home
challenge like I talked to one guy
probably spent five or ten emails back
and forth of him asking questions about
how to approach the problems and then he
just never did it you know other people
he'd give it to him they'd give it back
to you the next day and I'm like how'd
you do this in one night
so I also couldn't predict who would
accept the offer you know some people I
thought they were very very into it they
took something else and vice-versa but I
think the most important thing in who we
hired was that each team member had a
superpower and so I think when you're
building a team you really got to not
focus on weaknesses everybody has
weaknesses
not everybody has like super powers and
the superpowers really have to align
with what you need on the team at the
time when you're hiring that person and
so kind of what I mean by that is
the best and worst performers actually
have way more in common than the average
performers and so there's this book
called first break all the rules and
what they talk about in the book is that
you can't look at somebody who's a
failure and then take the opposite the
reason for this is that like success and
failure are pretty similar in how people
perform and so they give a number of
different examples and my favorite
example in the book they give one from
nursing they give one from sales they
give one from management but I like the
sales one because nobody wants to do
cold calls right so like what makes a
amazing sales person well the worst
sales people and the best sales people
actually both get super scared right
before they make the call and the reason
is is because the person that's the
great sales person takes it super
personally and they don't want to be
rejected so they get super nervous they
want to make sure that they have it all
dialed in and you know they really care
about like you know making the sale so
they get a little nervous the the worst
performers they stop there but the best
performers actually have another Talent
which is they enjoy confrontation and it
sounds weird but what it means is that
they enjoy the debate they enjoy like
trying to overcome the obstacles the
objections when people say no what do
they mean like is it no now is it no
period so they get into the they engage
with the person and they really enjoy
that process whereas the average
performer they just run through the
script they cross their fingers they
hope it works and so this was like super
mind-blowing to me because it's like the
best people and the worst people are
more correlated than the average
performers and you'd think well if I can
get this big team and we can move people
from B player to a player like it just
doesn't really work like that and so
I've seen it in my own team where like
they won't engage on a project they're
just not into it they just don't think
it's a good idea you can't really get
them to try very hard but the people
that just like keep slogging away they
never really have those like aha
thrus so this is where it's like you
know the complexity of the team is is
quite interesting so you want to find
people that are like super passionate
about it and will quit over something
because they care so so in the book they
kind of summarized it as you can't teach
talent like you can't teach somebody to
have a super strong opinion you can't
teach somebody to like feel the emotion
of other people you can't like teach
empathy
you can't teach people to revel in the
confrontation like you know we would
have a sprint planning and some people
would be like okay like that's my task
and then other people would like really
want to argue about like this is a dumb
idea like this isn't gonna work we don't
like it and at the beginning it feels
like this person's like fighting me
but you realize very quickly that if you
are right they'll get on board right
they'll get into it they'll see okay and
I see how you how you mean that and if
you're wrong you should know like you
want to know so it's much better to have
people tell you the truth you know you
know we're in LA you're celebrities
everywhere
get a lot of yes men right people just
want to hang around whatever you say
like you're right those people are
pretty dangerous so I think you want the
same thing in your data science team you
want people that will argue with you and
so you have to select for talent like
these and so kind of at the end of the
process I kind of started to see where I
had gone right and where I had gone
wrong in the interviewing process like
how do you actually tease these things
out how do you tease out you know you
could ask questions something like what
was the time when your boss was wrong
and you were right and you know people
are like I'll never say anything bad
about your previous job never talk
poorly about you know a previous team or
something like that and there's some
truth to that you don't want to you know
some people always have something bad to
say because they're always on the wrong
side of you know the team and they're
difficult people and then other times
you know they're very passion and they
care a lot about it and they have very
strong opinions and they remember so
being able to like figure this out is
very complicated
it's very challenging to build a team
but at the same time it's very fun
so in conclusion growing 150 fold so
that was a little bit of clickbait right
there we went from one client to 150 and
you know we're adding more but basically
you know we started with a MacBook and a
CSV file and by using the right tools
using the right processes and then
finding the right people we were able to
grow and so I think the order is very
important in in how you approach that
problem all right so here's the link you
can join my newsletter and I'm working
on a book like an e-book on this topic
so if you sign up I'll send you guys a
free copy of it when I'm done
any questions yep so I would say like
yeah so the question was what are some
of the superpowers of my team so so one
guy I found out like maybe a month after
he started was like doing a Cavill
competition and he had bought a GPU and
he was trying to like do some like hyper
opt tuning and stuff like this on the
weekends and so basically like that type
of passion I asked him like start
working on that for our product and so
he was like you know I didn't know that
he was interested in that and that was
like a little farther down on the
roadmap so he just started doing it on
his own even though it didn't like
really fit with where we were on the
product cycle so I would say just like
initiative and creativity and another
superpower was like somebody on our team
joined it was a it was like an innocence
project and so it was like how do we use
data to try and like mine this so it's
it's when you see people that like are
very interested in in the tools and the
and the concepts behind it and then they
can bring in the things that they're
learning
in their spare time back into the team I
would say those are two of the
superpowers yeah that's a great question
so the question was how to bring in a
data-driven mindset into an organization
that isn't necessarily technical I think
um you know at the beginning my
co-founder is a little bit less
technical than I am well he's a lot less
technical but at the beginning that we
we struggled a little bit with the okay
ours because they require like a lot of
commitment and then they require
measurement so you I should have to do a
lot of work to even just measure what
you're doing and so that's where like in
tracking our model performance we had to
go and find ml flow and we were trying
some different solutions before that but
we needed a place where we could track
this where everybody could see it so
that burned up a couple cycles you know
for for a person or two there's
definitely has to be like a buying and a
commitment you know because there is an
added cost to operating in this way I
think the a lot of the benefits are
deferred so you don't really necessarily
see them until later but I think like I
would say that by an if you can get the
buy-in you can start moving in that
direction but if you if you try to like
put the cart before the horse and start
just implementing some of these things
without people like really buying into
it they'll get neglected people get
pulled off of it they'll get read you
know reallocated to something else and
and it'll just fall fall in its face
and kind of not spent a full half-hour
they weren't right and some things that
you can't teach people so looking for
these contents so how does that change
or how do you approach that after
somebody is hired
you've already hired them and then you
start to see weaknesses or you see that
they didn't have to tell them you
thought are you kind of the mindset of
um you know we heard one person and I
had to let her go after nine days it
just I had done such a poor job
interviewing and they had gone through a
boot camp and so I took for granted that
they knew how to do a lot of stuff you
know other than that I've only had to
let one other person go I mean it's a
great question I think the fire fast
hire fast fire fast thing it's like a
little bit of a cliche and they're real
people you know and it's like if you're
kind of just burning through people it's
that's not really like the best strategy
so I think um I think making another
thing I think is that making somebody
productive can have a lot to do with so
it kind of goes back to that Deming
quote of 85% of the problems have to do
with like the wrong processes for the
team so what I found was that when we
had more platform tools when we had more
when we had kind of built out the the
structure of the team people could be
way more productive faster so it was
sort of like we would hire people so we
hired some junior people but we hired
him a little too early so they couldn't
really make the platform tools and they
weren't there yet to use them so they
weren't super productive but it just
kind of helped me see that we needed
tooling like tooling was very important
and so I hired some contractors to build
up the tools once we had those then the
people became more productive it doesn't
exactly answer your question but you
know every everybody that I let go I
wish I had let them go faster
like I waited too long
do you guys know Gary Vee Gary
Vaynerchuk I saw him on snapchat or
something he was you know doing his
thing and he said he fired one guy after
one day it took him a year to actually
like let him go but in his head he had
fired him and he's like I regretted it
and he goes I would wake up in the
morning and I think about firing the gun
I'd say I gotta give him another chance
and he goes it was torture
it was so torture it you know it really
weighs on you and you have this guy like
Gary Vee right he's super flamboyant
super outspoken and he's afraid to sit
down with an employee and let him go and
he said but he like cost that guy a year
because the guy never really was like
productive and the guy could have been
doing something else and so you know I
think it's one of those things where
it's it's sensitive you want to be kind
you want to like give people a chance
but there's also like just timing right
like they maybe would be good later but
they're not good at this stage
especially if you're small you know I
think people can hide in big
organizations like pretty easily you
there's no hiding in us in a
three-person company like it's just it's
a different beast so yeah
that's never happened I think I think
people you know I think people quit jobs
for a lot of reasons we I maybe just
don't have a big enough sample size but
I think you know if that were to happen
what I would do is I would I would thank
them for like coming up to me because I
think like you know we don't have that
much time on the planet and so I think
everybody has something that they can be
great at so I think to kind of waste
your time in an organization like that
it's um you know it's embarrassing to
get fired but it's also like you know I
think it's like a pretty strong move
just to say like this isn't working out
for me
and so I want to like go do something
else and sort of take that risk but if
somebody did that I would I would say
like hey like you know let's figure out
a transition period like let's find you
like you can start finding another job
and we'll figure out like how to to make
that work because I think there'd be a
certain level of honesty of that person
so I would want to respect that and and
help them transition out yeah
yeah I would say the the number one
thing is like skin in the game so I
would say all the all my stages have
always had like a certain level of skin
in the game when when I was in hft like
if the trades didn't work we didn't make
any money so it was like you know
there's some pressure there and then at
Facebook you know you have this like
huge scale and when I started I think we
had I think there was like 10,000 people
in the company and when I left there was
18,000 and so you know there's like a
billion users or whatever so you have
this like ratio of users to people so
you have a lot of levers you can pull
that the data sets incredible they kind
of track everything we kind of know that
now but yeah so I would but I would say
like my favorite hit by far has been the
startup because it's so much more
challenging like you have to be full
stack everything right like every
decision you make matters to the
business and so it's just it's more
engaging there's more skin in the game
like it's more fun in my opinion but
it's definitely harder like yeah
starting something from scratch is hard
yep
that's a great question so do you guys
know the movie Moneyball or the book
Michael Lewis I think that's like the
best model for hiring what everybody
thinks is predictive is really not that
predictive so if somebody says they went
to Harvard you know they're everybody
has this concept right now in their head
of like Oh Harvard but our team is like
I would say like if you if I knew
one thing like about a person it was
like did they do a casual competition or
not like I don't even really care how
they score like I would just I would
probably prefer that person to the other
person if that was my only thing I knew
about them so I would just say that I
really like Moneyball just because
there's a lot of biases and preconceived
notions that have nothing to do with
race or gender but have everything to do
with like you know educational
background and like corporate experience
and stuff like that like you could have
somebody that could be a killer at a big
company and they'd be terrible in a
startup so it just has really very
little to do with you know resume or
pedigree and all that stuff and I think
the other thing is like you guys all
know WordPress and Matt Mullenweg so he
has a he has a whole thing he talks
about where they don't hire people
through interviews they just don't
interview people they on board everybody
and give him a trial period and they pay
everybody $25 an hour for the hours that
they work so his point is like we're
distributed like even if you're a great
developer some people like to be
distributed and some people want to be
in an office so like people need there's
there's there's so many different
variables just to the organization that
you just don't know if somebody's would
be good and so instead of like hiring
somebody you give them a tryout right
and so they're kind of on the team and
let him let him go from there
so I think there's a lot of people have
done a lot of good thinking on this
topic but yeah I mean I think it's a
interesting challenge
all right
sounds good all right thank you thanks
guys
[Applause]